hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and in this one i'm going to
show you guys how to download and
install a mozilla thunderbird theme and
this right here is mozilla thunderbird
itself it happens to be an email client
obviously made by mozilla
where they offer add-ons where you can
you know change the theme just like
firefox or any other web browser uh and
this is you know where i do answer all
my emails this is my youtube email
central i do answer every youtube
email question comment and thank every
single new subscriber uh so this is you
know this is what i think this is
basically my hub and uh i'd like to you
know spice it up visually so i'll go
ahead and show you guys how to install a
theme
so i'm going to go into firefox right
here and basically uh to find a theme go
ahead and search uh
thunderbird themes
uh if you can spell it correctly and the
uh the first result will be
add-ons.mozilla.org and that is until
now uh as of today the only place i
recommend you get thunderbird add-ons
and here we're going to go um you can
just pick a section these are the
recommended add-ons so you know i'll
just pick one of these arrow thunderbird
add-on but obviously you can pick from
the side compact ones the modern ones
etc
uh basically what you're going to do is
follow the instructions that pop up
there are three very simple steps and
i'll be able to show you guys how to uh
you know how to go through these steps
real quick all you have to do is hit the
download now button
and firefox will say do you want to open
this up what i want to do is save the
file because opening it up obviously
isn't installing it so we're just going
to save the file hit ok
it's going to save right to our desktop
and if it doesn't save to our desktop
i'll show you how to move it there
or at least to move it to a memorable
place so some sort of uh place will
you'll remember where you can always
have it and where it will be installed
to thunderbird so here it is it is a dot
jar file so opening it won't do anything
hit the open containing folder button
and it'll be highlighted and i'm just
going to take this and drag it to my
desktop and just let go so now arrow
thunderbird that add-on is on my desktop
okay so i'm just going to exit out of
this and firefox so now when we go ahead
and open up thunderbird again this is
where we're going to have to find the
add-on and install it so go to the top
and go to tools
add-ons and here's the add-ons window
and in order to install a theme go to
the themes tab install and find exactly
that place where you had the add-on so
in this case it's on my desktop scroll
down there is arrow thunderbird
double-click it
and happens to just just go ahead and
say you know do i do i accept this
add-on do you know will it not harm my
computer hit install now
and obviously installing a theme will
require thunderbird to restart so that
button will be pressable just go ahead
and restart thunderbird and it'll
restart but the theme will not be
applied so you'll see right here it
opens right back up in the standard
thunderbird theme
so go ahead and go to tools and add-ons
again
and click the theme that you want to
apply
take use theme
exit out of thunderbird again
and restart it one more time and that
theme should be applied and this is
actually the first time i'll see the
theme along with you guys kind of nice
looking you know
so yeah this is how you download and
install a thunderbird theme so if you
guys are interested in using mozilla
thunderbird i highly recommend it for
anyone who uses email i am very serious
about this i am very glad i picked this
over anything like outlook
does have a calendar client built into
it thanks to an add-on
has a tasks list and everything and now
there are themes so thank you for
watching this uh hd tutorial guys i hope
it was helpful to you and uh you know
just go ahead and leave a comment if you
have any questions comments concerns
anything like that i like i said i'm
glad to answer them and that is
basically it thanks for watching guys
peace